okay guys jack is over there right now
and he doesn't see me he's over farming
potatoes and we're gonna play an epic
prank on him you ready
oh I just love farming I am Irish did
you guys know that I didn't react I was
just doing the face for the thumbnail
Jack is gonna die in a fire oh no in
Minecraft yeah yeah sorry Jack isn't
it's fine jack is gonna live jack is
gonna keep living in the fire guys epic
smash life don't forget oh no the new
thing is you have to have a pop-up show
up showing the subscribe button case
people oh yeah yeah it turns green did
you guys know you could subscribe to
youtube channels remember guys subscribe
smash my like but but dude at the start
of the video because you don't you know
you're gonna this one there's gonna be
one for the banks you know what just
subscribe don't even watch the video
hundred million subscribers yet the
question mark okay but when it happened
Felix I don't know dude stop could you
somebody but you're crazy
do we need a lot of potatoes we can hold
64 you're smart I have big brain how are
you so power of pyramids really focuses
the energy into my chakras okay I get
the big boat big boy are we getting
boats well it might be nice to have in
case we find cancer all right all right
thinking that 20 steps out here I see it
dude I'm the world chess champion it's a
good thing that you made everything in
slabs so that I can't use it yeah I
guess so annoyed was trying to figure
out how many I need I just convert them
all alright we had other set alright
guys so today we're we doing saying uh
which direction you want to go we're
trying to find horses and we're trying
to find tress Adel's saddles
Saito's shipwrecks sailing I think we
should head what is this direction west
because we came from east
you ready gamers okay we came from south
we came from east gamers let's go yeah
okay game from the e
so we go to the yeah can we hack you the
application music land fees I've ever
seen
oh I see snow bro what's your kind that
mountain it's all over others wolfies do
you have any bones did you make it all
into bone meal dude there's plenty of
scaly man's don't you stop even freaking
about it dude don't be such a mind crack
a look at that water my god
that is epic I already lost you somehow
oh they were right last very long does
it turn Wow it's okay so hit the water
you just broke your ankle on the way
ankle hurt can I walk okay oh my god
lover don't fall don't dig straight down
here no thanks don't think straight down
anywhere dude it's a hick and minecraft
mistake that is a hank in Minecraft
mistake right deal okay we found hump
khun's
yeah yeah spruce biome it's not good to
be in we need to be in like desert or
grass Plains I think a lot yeah I don't
think there's anything in this direction
okay let's switch to where do you want
to go south we came from south north nor
sounds good okay north let's climb this
mountain and let's look at the sunset
and we can appreciate how beautiful my
god
look at that beautiful cube this guy
wait it's my son that beautiful
beautiful cube of hydrogen
my son is canvas epicly hydrogen our God
we should sled before before or at least
plop beds with us yeah I wanted this you
know I you can't be big brain all the
time just go back it's terrible yeah
commit murder first oh is that a jungle
biome no no it isn't its greed enough
it's green enough for what to be a
jungle biome
no just a regular forest
dang it you know what we should do
whoa what follow me you being epic right
now I'm being extremely Pinsir mover at
maneuver ha ha behind ya trick that Wow
dumb epic minecraft tip you can trick
them creepers can't be fooled for once
okay we should probably go back I heard
the sound of pigs dying I was like there
yes let's find those dogs because I have
bones and we can tame them hello
beautiful can we see our pyramid from
here
not yet is that the city where is that
another one I don't know actually
oh my game Oh God I think that's another
liked heavily just now yeah I think this
is another village there's another
village right next to it yeah it's like
Ireland sweet is so close yeah it is who
it is dang this is another village
that's a cat oh I got no fishies these
people are alive here hello they won't
be for long if we stay the guys there's
a creeper right there I know if you know
this but creepers they go B they go boom
boom
Oh kitty oh they're so cute sounding
okay you guys got anything to borrow we
can't just go to villages and I'm not
stealing I'm borrowing okay pretty well
just like the Enderman yeah I need I
need these bookshelves dude okay grandma
book chat it's not stealing if I really
enjoy it who taught you these like okay
let me check it should be house when we
go west yeah and then we went north okay
I'll head back
yeah it's literally right here they're
so close that's crazy
I've never seen this bone so close
before - 730 - mm we could actually
build these villages together and make
like a giant village and then the
pyramid bigger and bigger
and then when this gets attacked by
mecca's you can you can live on the moon
and then
oh my god the pyramid looks awesome I
like this little doorway into it yeah
what's up flip-flop plop bleh it's bloop
oh oh I'm so sorry
bloop do you want to do you wanna tame
the dogs yes
first of all where do or do you want to
put our books would maybe because it's
Pitka okay I don't have any bones
I have buns I'll give me please sir can
you spare a boon no oh you need some oh
there's ask any man here I'm going to
kill him get my own Oh strong man get on
bone all right where are they you didn't
give me any bones breaker fracker
dude okay language seriously I get very
minecraft moments too okay I found them
they're at - 890 where we went before
and jumped from the water basically oh
my wait oh my oh my
hey tamed instantly you you got the I'm
gonna name mine blip I found another one
here but you're not here and I have no
ball okay well here okay
poof maybe I'll maybe I'll name mine
poof and you can do piss babe they love
it okay break it no baby go on no no
they don't prick these guys you guys are
loyal companions yeah no free work dogs
so freaky
no three gonna my watch unless in the
friction or of course dead then all
rules are broken anything goes wait what
it's my one pif why your poem a live
blog yeah it's almost like the naming
scheme is stupid what I can commit but
my one will be called Maya he and your
Maya ho okay cool I like that better
and then the baby will be my okay which
one is he
I don't know yours is first so that's my
eggnog a my mines my Yahoo oh my
he and who I don't know who we need died
alright we have any die yet you can grab
from the flowers okay I have pink die
I'm gonna make my my dog oh that's
awesome
okay I'll make mine minecraft light gray
come here
are you my job yeah there you go
pinky that's cute me nametags dude yeah
this is why we're suppose that out okay
I'm gonna put the die back in with the
mowers or with the wool did we bring
them with I think no okay you stayed
there epic adventure await but your
little small blue I think we should go
and fix the portal if you go through now
it takes us to one place all right but
then you can't come back yeah but how do
we fix that we have to destroy one of
them and then you're stuck yeah that's
how he's guarding and my he is guarding
play Oh Maya hoot come down you need to
come to the other side
wait I have a leash oh sit right yes
perfect big brain
nice nice guardians of the realm yeah
okay let's head out gamer let's go this
direction okay so you just want to
search okay well this is where the other
vision but we can just keep going you
can go like this way over summer sees
when I played first time everything came
so easily and now it's like I have to
search for sa ttle yeah your your world
spawn was really good you're like right
next to an oasis my my map is just
surrounded by water it's like 90% water
there's bunnies right here yeah there's
nothing really over here except water
okay well boats are good to people poets
are good for water maybe we find
shipwreck yeah no the boys are out
paddle board oh yeah should we bring
people puffs I mean hey Maya he in my
home yeah they need to see horrible
there's a point getting the dogs and
then not bringing them okay boat don't
disappear bag I think I'm their boat you
know you can
okay no no no I was just going to come
back to this port make this our harbor
but I don't like a harbor no and my look
I'll just forget where everything is and
then have to build a big boat this is so
awesome it's pretty cool actually I like
the two houses on this sign this one
looks like it looks like one of the
right looks like it has like an arm out
front it's getting ready to death are
you doing that no I can't look it in
swinging a Miss on that one oh yeah it's
gold sword better than diamond sword no
no Gold's awful it doesn't do that much
more damage than iron but it breaks
super quick alright
my heat let's go gamer my Yahoo let's go
my let's make some you should bring the
lead just in case we need yeah I have
one
okay nevermind I don't know how to say
this Jack but I think Maya he is a
little better than my home it sounds
like you knew exactly how to say that
sounds like somebody likes alright
alright there's only one way to sell
this smash like if you prefer Maya he
and smash like if you prefer my own
don't do that don't pit our dogs against
each other they're both epic bros dude
this is a weird cave look at this I know
what you know you want cold good tire
right on the side of his you wanna cold
we got them I brought your diamond
pickaxe with you yeah look at this dude
a coward that dies hey I may die but
right the best dog goes in the boat
first come on Maya he come on my my my
my one day we'll find child okay which
epic direction does this just keep going
see this is bad sure I like this better
this is good I see something in the
water on the right or what there it's a
water temple did we forget to bring
bed-sitting Jack I'm just checking this
is a boat yeah it's a boat right here a
boat here Bob and Bill's oh it's an
upside-down but those are better all
right there's our Australian boats Oh
all right stay there Maya he
I never know where the Chester ooh
enchanted leather a lot of wheat and a
lot of TNT and poison potato good don't
die let me Oh God
whoa this is a good chess oh god of my
thigh you get oh my god this is so
pretty this guy's orange in the water oh
god I might night but you get 16
emeralds Oh 15 Nuggets Rikers I guide a
leather tunic that has fire protection
three okay not the cap that is
protection more time on just so I can be
a shiny boy ha shiny boy be puppy I
really should use like the Sun and the
moon as guidance to the moon that's a
good game oh that made me cry cry don't
sing did we just have water in this
biome like wet yeah welcome to my head
they're like he's Irish he loves being
surrounded by water you feel like home
now you're welcome
flower biome shut up that's not a flower
Byam no but everything is to you okay if
you see a flower all right all right
oh you know what a kid because I care oh
no way he isn't never mind sorry wrong
what's up creeper so it's been epic Oh
like leg city bit
I want a desert temple can we have all
yeah hello me hot water here
I made a pee-pee I get it because it
reacts with the cold water and creates
an epic current hello damn we really
can't find it it'd be good if you Frank
desert we should be able to find Tara
here citizen is this okay I mean there
no there's still quite rare but yeah
oh wait cuz Layton just letting the
water here oh my ding ding oh he has a
harpoon be careful ah no I'm not freakin
with that my ho no nope the desert to
the desert how do you get a trident
you kill that a trader sent whoa I never
seen this this is a rare biome
right oh my toe
whoa I don't know what they have whoa
Wow - found this in me neither
it's awesome Oh God didn't get my dog Oh
God mind it might disappeared
[Music]
epic relog what it's in red sand can you
get dog out come on dog can you get on
land can you get my jet online nice God
is glitching thank you get mine now okay
come on dog
it's my idea don't land you just
destroyed the boat first cuz I might hit
him you know what caring about your pets
you know I've never hit my pet Terra
Cotta isn't it it's Terra Cotta its
mother flippin Terra Cotta girl is it
all Terra Cotta just different colors
where's my light grey Terra Cotta gonna
make some terracotta soldiers oh this is
like the only biome I haven't found in
mine yeah same
yes I think have you found the coral
yeah what oh I thought you were yelling
at whoa whoa whoa there's wooden stuff
down really yeah look over there it's
like hanging down there's zombies
everywhere bro you have zombies
following you - I know dawg do something
Maya Maya who I think accidentally
behind you bro oh okay where's the wood
see right down there on the other Island
over there to the right Scout the Senate
I think I think as a boat that's one
online whoa doggies we have a tree is
that but seriously I never seen that oh
god oh god no no oh god oh god oh my god
was like 500 million creeper different
what no it's regular wood
Oh doggy be careful teleport please lab
we should have brought bets
what's up ander man are you in the boat
now I I'm right behind you
I have to loop around cuz those creepers
are doing your soulful arrows I'm
lagging Oh God
oh my god eyes Oh was an epic shot I'm
almost dead thing I'm more worried about
setting off a creeper my dog following
me
shouldn't the skeletons be afraid of the
dogs I know they're kind of useless our
dogs wait no this is not a that's so
awesome this is a mineshaft a Minecraft
what your soulful arrows
it's a mineshaft come on Maya heat
please so cool why I'm just gonna my dog
the slowest dog in the world
I'm just gonna do this to try to speed
things I'm really worried that we're
gonna look come on whoo
what's your dog's name whoo Maya he your
dog's name it's it's whoo
what do you mean oh god there's a
creepier well this is your chest here oh
no I'm really hoping for a Sato what are
you doing I leave two seconds here eats
flesh rotting flesh
yeah I know and they fine you push okay
he pushed my bag do not it's like a
surface spawn the mine shaft so they are
like on top and side this is so weird
oh there's a spawn there's a villager
okay yeah that's oh god I thought you I
thought that would distract him and like
make him attack me instead he's the
weirdest minecraft servers yeah right
stop stopped up so here's the spawner I
think is it a poisonous pothole that's
way in dude we should go in from another
side I just want to see what scene oh
yeah this is an entrance yeah I don't
think it's a unless he's not from that
should we leave our yeah I found I find
a better entrance over here I'm coming
there's too many torches though oh
there's a car there's poison ivy comes
yeah and they're the worst
just block block block Oh Golden Apple
we can cure the guy now the one that we
just killed yeah oh the guy back home oh
I ain't going there
okay terracotta do your thing I never
seen one of these phones so close to the
surface it's really cool yeah me neither
then again maybe that's natural here
yeah if you have different coloring nah
nothing down here yeah I'm not finding a
sato still god I mean like the middle of
those spider webs and I still don't see
the spawner god it's right in the middle
Jesus oh I almost died yeah I'm not
going in today this is rough I kind of
want to just stop this spawner yeah I
think the poison ones are fine to stop
because they're so easy to find and
they're just really annoying damn right
below you small orders like right below
where you are oh no oh no oh no oh no oh
no run Jack and these poison can't kill
you yeah a lot of gold down here though
God if you miss the spider once it's all
it's all poisoned time yeah let's leave
this channel this chef sucks
no Jack please fight for Humanity okay
stopped becoming a boy I'm trying to but
the spawn was like right next to where
blocks to get in her we made it through
the knack a red terracotta orange
terracotta blue terracotta I don't know
how to fly on a banana banana banana
terracotta okay where's my dog Jack did
you leave my often teach you leave Maya
he oh they could be in the my show don't
worry we'll find him we'll find him I've
come back in a Pew it's gonna be all
right
oh the spawn is right here yeah kill it
but bye-bye spawner say your laughs they
hurt
see you last by bag Oh when you into
mine chefs it gets really no where's my
time I hear what okay he's here oh oh oh
oh and you match him that's so cute okay
as cool as his biome is we'll save it
and we can go back but I really want to
see a school as this biome is I hate
hate this I want to go it looks cool but
it's just
should we stock up on mats
Patera caught him how can he make out a
Turcotte it plate yeah well you make
claim and you make terracotta and then
you can make like different directly
people yeah bricks and stones I break
your bones
I don't I have unbreakable bond small
the potatoes so much calcium I get it I
understand big bones come on dougie it's
pretty cool and pretty cool to find this
to be honest especially when you were so
cool that we both found it at the same
time for the first time yeah all right
Maya heat go inside don't be scared come
on no Maya
why am i dog not listen to me Maya hey
come on doggy come on come down thank
you there we go come on don't be scared
they're so slow in water your dogs you
need to grab it yeah thank you we on a
boat again everybody all right well that
was a nightmare almost got you in dog
kill bruh I almost got myself killed
almost ended the series you know what we
persevere we fat out I got a Golden
Apple which is good but other than that
we can cure our village boy oh I think I
see a boat really yeah yeah can you find
settling boats I don't know but we might
find something we might find a treasure
map a lot of enchanted leather I don't
have any room and I'm also dying yeah I
don't think whatever not cool that's my
boy sorry just need to eat once that's
okay that's okay
we're bros we can have each other's whoa
it's a treasure map here maybe we can
follow that should be closed by the it's
usually fairly close to where you get
them right okay we gotta go I need
rotten flesh or spiders eyes lead oh my
faithful scientists eat east OOP I poop
you I poop your poop it's bumpy cars
bumpy boats
you're scaring Maya whoo hello Maya who
it's me your papa he's scared of you he
says he doesn't like Maya he don't be
afraid your head is freaking out why
focus Maya who says it does it wants to
change my who says oh wait we drove past
the treasure oh why is this there's an
arrow here that's doing a weird thing
you see that I think we drove fired
poison
it's possible you have the map lead oh
yeah it's here and now I know that
matter the treasures are always in sand
is that true
I think so oh shoot I don't have a
shovel do you have a workbench then I
can make one no I don't have a new one
Derek wood oh that's enough all right
you start digging
I'll give you usually not that deep all
right do you want to look at the map
good cos he can't as many times as this
happened to me it's amazing then I still
yeah I'm always like let's go on an
adventure with a full in I know that
feeling bro okay and finding it yet you
really should just make some bring some
TNT for this doesn't that I think the
chest can explode no oh maybe not I used
a creeper to find one once missed a big
brain
they called me mr. bigger brain oh I
like that the trees are hyper far away
and I chopped down one okay so the chest
should be yeah chest you find it just
where are you
oh no I'm calling out to it that mixes
oh this is claim great treasures
generating beach biomes and rarely
generate on on what rarely generate
underwater oh my god oh my god how we're
even it was right on top of us they swam
up to get air that was right next to it
oh you left your dogs and your yeah you
can get calm him Maya he is okay pop I
just went to the store he went to buy
you food I went to buy food where's
what's it what's that - 23 - 24 hundred
babies are chasing me I don't think
we're that far away from our base no we
weren't that bad oh we're my stuff like
you should get it you should get a
trident
every time hey that really didn't take
you long to yubi heck what did you do to
this place jack I didn't do nothing oh
there's another creeper swimmin okay why
is there a guy swimming with your
hey get out of there
Maya who defend yourself no creeper oh
no me young
do you have my armor at all no I have
another so you do know these are the
iron ones I had okay thank you
my god they keep entering the boats I
think you just lost some stuff because
explosion oh man no they're at the
bottom for some reason they keep
spawning here really annoying Sirius
sucks relax jack this is an epic journey
we're so finding that treasure by the
way yeah I'm not leaving here without
that I think we're close
did we lose the treasure no I have it
it's literally here it should be here
imagine like swimming up to get fresh
air and then reverse shark is there to
eat you most of the time the chest
generates buried in a beach so they'll
have a sand or gravel block covering
them we have the worst luck with
treasures yeah ah oh my god it has all
iron it any diamonds whoa it was worth
it it was that was definitely worth it I
need to get rid of some stuff no egg
well you can just put it in there
heart of the sea is good I can put yeah
yeah what I can grab the ever do because
I can stack it and the ayran okay grab
what you can
I grab rest bye bye treasure map Oh God
good job bro
thanks bro all I did was dig until I
wanted to not dig in it can you grab the
diamond you've destroyed this entire
place
Maya here we found it that was awesome
my Yahoo this is fair boat do you have
any more food I feel like we should go
back cuz I don't have any I have some
bread and fish and petits rotates
potatoes keep your eyes peeled you never
know what you find on these shores
nothing except really rare stuff that we
don't need yeah in my solo on I have
loyalty in a book that I'm ready to put
in a trade never again oh boy I want a
loyalty unbreaking no now I'm breaking a
loyalty mending superpowerful try to
epic that's how you know you feel true
but our tours like
I wish I could do that I'm for me oh boy
that's awesome
oh god oh god oh god what you do um I
try to get your dog onto the boat and
the lease just teleported across the map
it's fine you're holding it uh he is
bouncing all over the place he's next to
me you're holding him okay I don't know
how to get rid of the leash then
right-click on the dog again
I can't oh you don't see the dog can you
drop it with a cue no it's not in your
inventory
well he's following me it's fine so
weird I thought I broke your dog don't
break my dog bro well we might have lost
the lead then no we need it as I only
see I only see my dog okay I found our
first city so it should be to the left
yeah it should be down here lefty lefty
lefty loosey kitty cat I'm not gonna do
anything to you stop freaking out yeah I
see it yeah I could see the smoke before
I could see the Pirelli okay I see it I
just dug up don't what nothing
is that brain working bro no oh it's
good to be home what's up
oh no zombie don't worry blip blop I
protect you from jumbee jumbee don't be
and should we put like armor and weapons
and everything in the same chest yeah
that's a good idea I think I'm in this
one hey blip blop blip blop blip blop
blip blop blip blop
beep happy everybody's home sent you the
big brain
you know what blip blop you get sweet
berry now you've been so good there you
go blip blop I won't feed it to you
because you'll unleash unleash the beast
okay that was horrible well we
persevered we made it through
which one did the Terra Cotta boy yeah I
don't know we said we'd find a treasure
and we did well we didn't find it you
wanna go fishing bro maybe maybe we can
make the can we make an enchantment
table we should probably do that
actually let's make it on top there yeah
I was literally just thinking about make
more books bookshelves need 15 yeah but
you don't need it oh let's see
oh she's interesting friend from other
round Oh
small small brain do you like it easy
he heard word he and tripadvisor about
our I read on Yelp don't forget to rate
5 stars do I'm sorry 5 stars thank you
we give you five sorry he went into the
he went into the house I'm gonna welcome
it yeah welcome in this is your home now
you might have thought oh I'll just come
for a visit no you good job bro okay so
enchantment table I think you need
obsidian for it Oh Frank you need okay
do we yeah um what else
um just small stuff and what do smokers
do I don't know
never used one no I never me neither bro
okay well I can go obsidian from down
below
god it's Yuri are you I'm going down to
get the obsidian okey doke trying to be
an organization yeah you better or else
not five-star on Yelp that's for sure oh
yeah well maybe do better job yeah
instead of asking for reviews at the end
of it every goober driver boom just drop
that our villager is gone ah man the
prison you broke out of jail him prison
could not contain him you know that
suits a beast we just got the Apple to
he tore through the wall and rebuilt it
for his dam yeah what a mad lad want to
party with him I know I don't heard
stories but that guy that's why we try
to keep him in jail it wasn't to cure
him it was to contain him it was to save
us
you just saved humanity big man how are
you doing okay who wants to have babies
me me me me me
cool cool cool cool I give you baby I
give you baby-making power you don't
have those privileges the power of wheat
yeah that's good keep making Frick
that's awesome
make them free they can go freaky
hee-hoo okay please do you have one book
anyone back no we have paper though if
we get leather we can make a book
sorry guys so sorry sorry guys
okay it has been done before the great
big brain let's put the and Chapman
table like right in the middle okay it
is done um we can't and you explain it a
lot of space around it how do I get up
there
oh that's annoying hmm what we could
just put it here yeah I might need to
add one because you need a you need a
space between it all so like this that's
fine I'll put it here yep oh very epic
well the same thing happen with
bookshelves then yeah this doesn't make
any sense
but okay all right line chomp the
fishing run what do we get look at the
sea look at the sea come on baby I think
I'm too low level yeah I am I'm ever 23
I Kentucky oh we don't have any lapis I
do just got some bro okay
fishy rod we can get on breaking 2 or
breaking one or on breaking one nah so
or we can get sweeping edge too we only
have as far as out of 14 though we need
more bookshelves
did you get my bookshelves no I sing the
song
[Music]
dude please don't please stop that okay
now we can get a lure to okay yeah I
know that's not 426 I'm not there yet
and we have no spawners I can't firm
should I put lapis in this one oh yeah
yeah that is very well yes yes I dream
it necessary quite like a pond close by
hey Jack
are you doing your firming her no no I
don't know I didn't know you could do
that let go let go of my ax he say
psyche right now see my fishing rod is
almost broken already
oh god no that was happening ok our pond
again whoever finds first wins just two
boys to fishers Oh God I found a
tripwire hook wow we can get a dispenser
and put or it looks like you have a big
one what I cut you know I'm farming and
fishing at the same time this place is
too crowded for my liking
oh well a found fish come out fish I
know you want it I know you want this
sweet tasty lure dirty fish got another
one nice fish just like real fishing
yeah trying to avoid the spider love
fishing peaceful over here about the
sand one yeah this guy sucks
what again hit him oh I got bottle of
water
alright from those alright even though
those bottles of water in the game
alright it's been hydrated is Archie
fueling that oh I'm gonna get this fish
faster than you could say fishy dishy Oh
you can't jump ok you jump up there you
go oh you had the fish piece fish what
is wrong with my fishing rod come on
it's quicker if you scream at it ah it
worked
Wow
right but you did that to scream on my
neck it didn't work the louder you
scream the quicker it is no don't be you
know don't be maybe we should go through
the nether again I was literally about
to say that yeah let's get some levels
boy okay dougies come on come on doggies
I don't like you being so far away
Oh villager ooh bad villager oh really
get the Apple uh yes and you also need a
potion oh dang but we can do it we've no
brewing stand we can make one
Oh your ideas are so innovative and
crazy hey take him in here come on buddy
come on Frankenstein come on haste at
all oh yeah dummy you dummy dumb you so
dumb you so dumb you got trapped by two
big brains huh huh but wait what's he
coming oh thank you
dude he said your mama lame whoa my mama
ain't lame my mama is happy girl with so
many achievements look at that progress
oh man look at all that basic progress
okay another time
what's the coin grab your friends oh you
just went you just did okay grab is
everything in this for me well killing
and er dragons I guess would you
remember that if you go through the
nether you can't come back do you
remember just checking that you even
remember that just wanna make sure cuz
you went through that nether very
quickly okay I'll come get you you know
that the gasps sound is actually not
just cat and then what we recorded this
cat for the sound effect I know you told
me already didn't I yeah what did you
know it I can tell you the two plus two
is four man
believe it it's not we brain must be so
large okay so wait did you enter again
then no I bet you're just right inside
for sure do you ever use courts to do
anything in this game no no not really
you could just make the white blocks
where she looks good we go through again
wait yeah Wang what are we doing we want
to get rid of this one right no you
can't have to go through and destroy the
one that's on the other side yeah wow I
love this one this is the best I don't
even have a diamond pickaxe is me so
it's up to me huh that's very dark let
me use my big brain here so where would
we enter next time we enter didn't enter
right Tom Cruise died fat did you know
he hung up from the airplane he does his
own stunts so epic
did you know Tom Cruise did you know Tom
Cruise believed in space alien yeah
ocean ocean man grabbed me in the sand
what you brought the boat right why are
we never prepared for this is what
happens you try to make a let's play you
just don't think it's like I need to
fill space hi I'm Phil space to me in
the ocean with the little fishes Ben
don't image swimmer Lambie it's good
that we both went because I was
necessary yeah it's good that both of us
went with two empty inventories but
brought nothing it's just a you made a
mistake first and then I didn't it just
for yeah it's good that I went in
without sinking and then you had time to
think and then did the big brains of a
yes series we don't know her yeah
usually you know in Let's Plays there's
one person that knows what they're doing
we're gamers not thinkers uh see these
these are birch trees you can tell that
they're birch because of the way they
are
Wow come here cow it's not that it's
just a next phase of life yes you're
entering next phase oh look at that
pyramid yes seeing it it's so good it
brings me joy wait why are we wanted
another to farm levels pool a level 26
now should be able to do the thing okay
so now you go through and make sure it
work thank you I'm gonna enchant my
fishing please please fish blush fishing
rod this lure to Ma enchanter baby on
breaking three lure to baby can you
check the it just like go through just
like you're gonna have to okay I'll do
that
you take the fishing rod Go Fish no no I
mean cats don't go but I have to but
don't go no don't take me back I have to
do this okay it's my destiny but wait no
bye-bye
I see your underside to you so I can
just get pulled through as well I forget
what the other portal is okay so where
did you end up now the same one again
okay so if you go back you come back
here on my way back I was just going to
run through the nether again probably
died oh no did it respawn respawn
see this is why I made you go wait I
mean you just get infinite obsidian yes
but it's not that rare how do we fix
they to be can't we yeah I think once
we're in the nether we have to go as
close to this coordinates as possible
and that's the only way like and then
build another portal and then then then
the link up it's okay I can do it well
luckily we got enough obsidian for
another one okay I'm on my way back I
need to sleep sleep you can sleep all
you want but just dream of me out here
alone
closing my eyes and think of you but
hope that every time you close your eyes
so the coordinates are mm that's pretty
easy to remember bro we recording for
one hour and 40 minutes bruh bruh and it
now okay
Amit now okay game race sleep epic
ending sleep I can't sleep for some
reason oh oh did you break the bed Oh /
like gamers smash like if you think
Felix should never be allowed to play
again well you haven't tried to pursue
Malay dat city after 50 million outros
much now just now it's still relevant
just download it